Good Times create weak people weak
people create bad times bad times create
strong people strong people great great
times what I want people to get is you
got to know where you are in your life
and where you are in history and you got
to learn to take advantage of it you
can't complain that it's winter during
winter if you start a business in Winter
and you succeed 60% of all Fortune 1,000
companies that are alive today the
biggest some most successful companies
could have been born in any one of those
Four Seasons they were all born in
Winter wow a recession or depression
from FedEx to Disney Disney was
depression FedEx was a recession I can
walk you through the mall so that
process makes you strong and what
changed my life was finding that part
that's inside of all of us that will not
give up